we're learning new secrets from inside
the kitchen of one of the world's most
successful and influential restaurants
Noma has been named the world's best
restaurant four times in the past decade
now the Danish eatery is out with the
new cookbook the Noma guide to
fermentation it's not your typical
collection of recipes some dishes take
months to make and may require some
bizarre ingredients first on CBS this
morning Roxanna sabirah takes us inside
nomás new location in Copenhagen in
nomas three kitchens fifty-five chefs
for every ounce of energy into each dish
but beyond the bustle is a room running
on patience how long will you be waiting
for this bread to ferment about three to
four months this is no must fermentation
lab banana bread we're microbes and mold
make magic add some salt pack it into a
jar wait for millennia people have
fermented food to keep it from spoiling
turning milk into yogurt soy beans into
sauce and cabbage into kimchi but chef
David Zilber and his team are pushing
the boundaries of pickling how many new
tastes would you say you have discovered
here hundreds in this fermentation
chamber it is hot about 140 degrees
Fahrenheit and it smells rich and funky
some of the things they are fermenting
in here are clams garlic and stale bread
more than a hundred of their successful
experiments make up a new book the Noma
guide to fermentation well I'll give you
a little taste of that recipes range
from simply salting and sealing plums in
a bag add it to your salad dressings
poured on top of your yogurt to building
a fermentation chamber with racks and a
heater it's probably not something I
would do at home possibly not but it's
easier than you think we try and ease
people in through the levels of
difficulties everything for the fresh
fruit is to salt and mason jars and then
it's a more complicated things like
let's say vinegar or mesos or
grasshoppers or grasshopper down
yeah that's right garam a sauce
fermented for months smells like vinegar
made from grasshoppers oh that's
actually very good grasshopper I didn't
soured pickled cabbages pickled
coriander absorbers countless
experiments this is a vegetable chorizo
only 5% make it onto the menu the
grasshopper is made the cut
mixed with wild greens atop of barley
flatbread thank you not as Francis
mm-hmm
the fermentation is like it's building a
tiny little bridge between each
ingredient head chef Rene Redzepi says
fermentation is so fundamental to Noah's
gastronomic success he puts a pickled
element in nearly every dish now the
secret's out you put a lot of work and
recipes into this book and now you're
sharing it with other people including
your competitors yeah why we believe
that if people just did this a little
bit cooking would be so much better and
easier so you have to share that why say
that so if somebody takes this book and
create something new will that help you
one day of course that would be amazing
after all he says fermentation only gets
better with time for CBS this morning
Roxana Saberi Copenhagen pretty brave
Roxana to eat the grasshoppers did you
do it without you grasshopper
no pickled well I don't really have the
right pairing wine for grasshopper so
that would keep me from dying no Nora no
no but we do want to go to Noma we do
want to tell yeah yeah I'm gonna try
that and and at Noma I need to grass up
yeah maybe I would too